Jeffrey will you write on days when you
don't feel inspired yeah yeah I mean I
always joke my inspirations I had to pay
rent and I have to yeah have bills to
pay so that's yeah you yeah you I mean
there are but there are times where I
will just I will give myself a break
because I'm like okay I've been working
you know I've been writing every day for
ten days and if I want to take a day off
it's okay like so that's that's usually
what happens with me it's like I don't
it's yeah I learned to not do it I cuz I
read a great quote summer night and I
some making Google and find out who said
it but they were talking about how you
know people you don't wait for your muse
to come you know like you grab the muse
and you stripe it down to the chair and
you choke it until it you know work
because yeah you will writers will find
any excuse to not write you know will
you know it's like working out or doing
anything that's that you want to do but
you're a little like a fearful that
you're not going to reach out for it
you're gonna find any excuse to put off
writing so you have to learn like not to
you know you can't say whether you're
waiting for inspiration because you can
inspire yourself if you start writing
even if you write it called pages a day
even if it's crap you just train your
brain to write so it's you know it's a
chemical thing that you you do if you
make yourself write every day at a
certain time I don't do this because I
again roll out of bed and will start
writing pretty early but you know I
during the earlier times there were when
you know when I was kind of like I don't
feel inspired I would just do that I
would just get up and be like alright
I'm gonna write two pages even if it's
like awful stuff and then you you do
actually get your brain wired to where
you'll that those two hours will start
coming and your brain will start
percolating for before noon hits and
you'll start writing and you know so you
it you have to kind of train yourself to
do it but I understand like I understand
that I don't feel inspired today or
whatever but there comes a point where
you have to make sure you're not just
doing that because you're afraid of
writing because you you know I was
talking to a friend mine recently and
you know she was complaining about how
she's like she's written this you know
you mungus outline this humongous
treatment for and she just hasn't
started a script and I said well because
you know when you finish the script you
have to give it off and it's like you're
one step closer to like handing over
people so you're like stuck in this this
area and a lot of times that's why we're
procrastinating because we know once we
start writing
and we finished that script we have to
give it to somebody you know and that's
when the judgment comes so I think
that's all a ton of reasons Oh
you know that's where that not feeling
inspired is just like I think that's
just kind of not wanting to write really
also - because you're close to your
characters and I'm not sure if this is
the same for horror genre but that you
you're losing your friends in some sense
because that's who you've been spending
time with right so handing it off is
like almost ending a relationship
ya know it's it there is a weird place
you get when you write something you
love it and you're ya in and you want to
hand it off and you want people that
read or read it to just love it as much
as you do and if they don't immediately
you're like you know yeah there's like a
it's like you're saying goodbye you're
ending something but then then it's like
sending them off and having a people I
can go why were you in a relation with
that saying that's enough hideous choice
for a partner what were you thinking so
you don't want people to like not like
your stuff - when you hand it off so
it's um you it's it's like when you
audition when you go up in an audition
in front of people that you don't know I
mean you're you're putting yourself up
there and basically even if you're being
a character though you still feel like
you're like all right love me and want
me for this part and if you say no then
you're rejecting me so that's you know
that's that's just something it's it's
really hard to like no matter how
successful you get or how long you've
been around it's hard to let that go you
know even now I like if I get a pass on
a script you know it still stings a
little bit even if it's a place that I
know it's not right for you know
you